if you look at western academies
universities who are the people teaching
the jewish history jewish scholars who
are the people teaching european history
mostly christians and seculars who is
teaching the islamic history
who is teaching the islamic history is
the question
it is the jewish scholars christian
scholars
atheistic scholars or in some cases
outright you know people who have no
beliefs or anything like that people who
have no beliefs at all they have nothing
to defend even they are teaching the
muslim history when it comes to the
english language in the western world
very few muslims are involved in the
history of study unfortunately
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back to the realist podcast
in the dunya the three muslims podcast
today we're joined with another very
special guest the man himself
thank you so much for having me hi baby
again the pleasure is all ours
alhamdulillah so for those who don't
know you why don't you give a quick
brief about yourself your journey in
islam and some of your work
okay bismuth
and i live in london with my family i'm
a student of history
i also collect historic
objects like coins and manuscripts and
books
so one of my passions
in life is to preserve our heritage
and i spent much of my time and
finances on that so
that's one of my passions in fact some
some would say it's an obsession
some people in my family my wife my kids
all of them they see me busy with
history and historic objects so
that's my passion and i've been involved
in dao for the last i would say the best
part of 15 years
and i've been studying on and off i'm a
student i'm a broken student of islam
i'm not a consistent student so there is
always a break in the middle sometimes
longer
than the previous breaks but
alhamdulillah
a is a dynamic journey i'm enjoying
every single minute of it as long as
as long as we are on the right path i
believe
even if we are slow in making progress
as long as we are on the right path
inshallah we'll get there one day so
this is a summary i studied history at
the university of london my bachelor's
was in history my masters was also
in history and i am and now i'm
planning to pursue a phd inshallah when
allah wills um
in history also so that's the plan
inshallah
inshallah
i mean
so uh anyone who knows speaker corner
has watched speaker's corner debates and
all that for the past i'd say decade or
so would definitely recognize your face
masha allah you have been very active in
the taoist and also your debates with uh
for example james white and other people
honestly to in my personal opinion i
love them so much i think they were
amazing so jazakallah for all of that
and
you also wrote a book
you know speaking about history he wrote
a book talking about
basically the islamic contributions and
how islam was one of the best things
that happened to mankind the books
titled islam's war on terror a
historical consideration so
let's go into that a little bit
inshaallah because a lot of people one
they don't value history we had dr steph
curious on we talked a little bit about
why history is important so check that
video out as well insha'allah to all the
viewers but people don't understand why
you know history is important islamic
history muslim history and islamic
contributions to the west because
there's this narrative nowadays that
islam is you know just a religion of
terror and
that we have no societal contributions
and we're just barbaric and sharia law
xyz
so
what's this difference this alternative
narrative the true narrative of what
really happened
look history is very important because
allah uses it for muslims
it is more important than possibly any
other
group in the world why because our
scripture
what we call allah's word the quran it
consists of history in fact i would say
nearly 30 percent of the quran is
history history in our eyes because we
believe what allah is describing what
allah is explaining is history okay
because it is allah who is sending it
down
to secular historians it is not
necessarily history these are legends
these are myths to some of them they
think adam never existed abraham never
existed so there are people like that
who think like that and because they are
secular in the outlook they are
naturalists
they don't see any physical evidence of
abraham's existence or for that matter
for adam's existence they think they've
never existed because there's no
physical empirical evidence but we
believe in the metaphysical world we
believe in the supernatural we believe
allah is the one who revealed the quran
we believe allah exists and he is the
one who spoke with us through
his prophets and he sent down
revelations therefore whatever he tells
us is true it is by default the truth so
that's why the quran
tells us the stories of previous
prophets and some of the struggles with
their respective authorities at the time
for example abraham uh dealing with his
king joseph dealing with his king moses
confronting the pharaoh or the uh
heroic
establishment so all of these things are
there in the quran so it is absolutely
crucial for us to know our history allah
is teaching us the importance of history
in the quran by telling us these stories
okay on top of that history is very
important for us to know
for us to
better understand the present
and to be able to predict the future or
to possibly make a future better having
learned from the past so if you know the
past well you will take lessons from
your past you will learn from it and by
doing so you will be
living your present uh to the best of
your abilities and at the same time
you'll be making things better for the
future inshallah having learned lessons
from your past
that's another reason to know history
also
furthermore
history is important because your
enemies are using it against you
your enemies
islamophobes islam hating entities
around the world
in some cases governments are using your
history against you they are distorting
your history they're spinning it they're
putting the wrong spin on it and they
are throwing it back at you right and
because we are not trained in history we
don't know our history we're not able to
defend our civilization right so in
order to be proud of your history in
order to be
uh
in order to be uh how can i put it you
know
in in order to be very very aware of
your history uh you have to study it and
doing so will give you the ability to
defend your civilization
where there are virtues where there are
achievements where there are luminaries
to defend you will defend them
effectively because you know the history
but if you don't know your history your
enemies will throw
partial history at you or distorted form
of your history at you or lies outright
lies at you and you won't be able to
defend because you are you are simply
not afraid away whether this is even
your history or not so
it's happening in india today it's
happening in the west islamophobia is a
reality we don't even hide it anymore
you know there are there are people on
news channels politicians
pseudo-intellectual pseudo-historians
are using your history
without
having to face much
trouble or much
challenge for muslims so i believe
muslims need to study the history more
and more we have been very negligent in
particular towards our history we have
neglected neglected it criminally i
believe we are
criminally negligent towards our history
so it's very important for us to
appreciate the history
learn
not all of it i mean it's impossible for
one person to know all your history but
you can also focus always focus
on a particular point of your history
you can master it and then you can
always represent it
if you look at other people
our counterparts like the christians and
the jews
if you look at
western academies universities who are
the people teaching the jewish history
um
jewish scholars
they are teaching jewish history who are
who are the people teaching
let's say european history mostly
christians and seculars
secular scholars some of them are not
even christian
who is teaching the islamic history
who is teaching the islamic history is
the question
it is the jewish scholars christian
scholars atheistic scholars or in some
cases outright you know people who have
no beliefs or anything like that um i
mean even atheism is a belief in my
opinion okay it's a belief system we can
go into that if you want but
but people who have no beliefs at all
they have nothing to defend even they
are teaching the muslim history
so the only people missing from the
scene are unfortunately muslim
professors muslim scholars
who are
who are absent from
schools of history or history
departments in major universities in the
west in particular okay you may find one
in one or two historians in the muslim
world
uh teaching in the local languages like
the arabic language let's say in the
arab world urdu language in pakistan and
the hindi language in india i mean most
historians in india write in the english
language but there are
people who are teaching in the local
languages but when it comes to the
english language in the western world
very few muslims are involved in the
history of study unfortunately
yeah subhan allah you know it's amazing
you mentioned it because um even myself
uh when i learned about certain points
just you know maybe a few hundred years
ago it's not even necessarily islamic
history but it was a huge turning point
like for example world war one the end
of it my teacher was telling me that we
wear these poppies in canada we go
around like so proudly wearing them and
they distribute them in stores and
schools and
they talk about this like great enemy
that that you know the west fought in
world war one and the longest time
wallahi for so long like maybe 19 years
i didn't know they were talking about
the muslims i don't know they were
talking about the ottomans and that's
when the ottoman empire fell that's like
when the islamic leadership fell and
then everything changed and these are
things that they don't they don't teach
you they don't talk about they'll talk
about the canadian side the western side
the european side
but and they'll talk a lot about world
war
which they should obviously it's a very
you know
important part of our recent history
but they don't talk about islamic you
know contributions to the west they
don't talk about maths and sciences and
law and how you know europe even
translated some of our literature and
then took some of our laws and so on and
so forth
and obviously you know if anything i say
is incorrect you know jump in and then
correct me please but this is just what
i know so far
listen there is one side uh let's say
you mentioned the first world war
there's one side the
that the the ottomans were one of the
parties in the war and
uh coalition
a coalition fought the ottomans and
ottomans were also
part of a coalition
the germans and the ottomans were
one party let's say and
britain
france and
america were another party right uh so
you see what you have to understand is
this is one side of the coin the other
side of the coin is that even from the
western side even from the let's say
from the british side
there were hundreds of thousands of
muslims who gave their lives
right uh to to fight for the freedom of
the british empire okay or to fight for
uh let's say the the honor and the
dignity of the british empire rightly or
wrongly is another question altogether
where they're right in doing doing this
is a separate question the point i'm
making here is there were hundreds of
thousands of muslims who gave their
lives
for the british empire in the first
world war
okay
1.4 million people died
soldiers i'm not talking about the the
masses uh when we talk about the
casualties
uh of war
during the first world war they run into
hundreds of millions okay collectively
uh two world wars killed 200 250 million
people collectively both wars killed
250 million people these were the
bloodiest conflicts in the history of
humanity to date
all the wars put together previously
uh did not kill as many people as were
killed
during these two world wars the first
world war and the second world war so
all the conflicts put together
uh previously in the recorded history of
humanity for the last 2000 years let's
say right
we don't have so many people dying okay
people can argue all the weapons were
different and there was there were less
people on on the planet that's why there
were less casualties fine but point
still stands right that most people
uh thus far up to that that point up to
the point of the second world war most
people were killed by these two wars in
human history okay and then
afterwards many more conflicts took
place in the 20th century 20th century
was the bloodiest century of
human history but that's another point
it's a separate point but but coming
back to the first world war
there were
hundreds of thousands of indian
muslims and sikhs and hindus of course
also
in lesser numbers they joined
the the conflict and they gave their
lives and there is physical evidence of
that by the way right there are names
upon names there are lists upon list
there is a french scholar i forgot his
name who has produced a lot of work
on the history of muslim soldiers
in the british army during the first
world war okay
so
uh
they gave their lives for the british
empire
so those islamophobes who are always
talking about muslims living in the west
as parasites we are here
and we are taking the jobs away
and we don't belong to the western
civilization
we are outsiders we are foreigners we
are immigrants
and we bring our extremism and our
barbaric and misogynistic ways with us
all these things we hear very often on
the mainstream media and
uh in the mouths of some bigoted
politicians right we hear this rhetoric
all the time but what we need to reverse
uh
i mean when we when we what we need to
do is we need to turn the tables and ask
them that what you call the western
civilization okay
in its current form do you know how many
muslims gave their lives to protect it
to preserve it to keep it alive do you
have any idea as bad or as good as it
may be
we're not discussing that point how good
or how bad it is
how
it is today
and whatever remains of the western
civilization do you have any idea as to
how many muslims actually gave their
blood
to keep this tree alive okay hundreds of
thousands during the first world war
plaques were given to muslim soldiers
who died in the war
they were there there were copper
plaques
given
to
muslim families in india with the name
of the deceased soldier
and
around the rim
it was written
he died
for
our honor
and um he died for on something like our
honor and uh
i forgot the details
um
yeah
something like that but the word honor
is there i can quickly look at one of
the plaques okay so these copper plaques
were given to the families of the
deceased okay 1.4 million of them
were manufactured
what does that show you 1.4 million
soldiers died
in the first world war okay and hundreds
of thousands of them were muslims okay
this is one side of the coin the other
side is the ottoman side as you
mentioned rightly ottomans were part of
a coalition with the germans and in fact
there were cases where some muslim
soldiers even refused to fight
against the ottomans or even refused to
fight in this war
there was a massacre of some muslim
soldiers in singapore it's it's a
well-known massacre
where muslim soldiers refused to fight
they said we're not going to fight
against our muslim brothers the ottomans
so they were put against the wall and
shot dead by the british military yes
absolutely they were executed right
there's another example where some
pashtun
uh tribal
uh muslims from current day pakistan
they
they went to iraq to fight
on one of the fronts they refused to
fight
and they came back
uh by land they came back on on camels
they came back to their territory
current pakistan so there are examples
like that as well
on both sides you see muslim sacrificing
their lives
okay so so this is why
knowing the nuances of history is very
very important right muslims sacrifice
their lives for what we call the western
civilization today and muslims also
sacrificed their lives for what we call
the ottoman caliphate
in the 1920s
okay so
we have to know these nuances for the
reasons i already discussed earlier that
if we know this history we can properly
defend our civilization our
contributions to other civilizations for
that matter okay so whatever remains of
the western civilization
muslims
have
given their blood and sweat to make
make it what it is today okay and this
doesn't start
or end with the first world war okay
the beginning is very very early muslims
were there from the very start beginning
with britain
or even europe if we talk about muslim
contribution to european intellectual
development okay
even later on to this day muslims are
contributing to the western civilization
so muslims have always had a very
powerful positive presence within
uh the cultural and historic landscape
of the western civilization okay this
has to be remembered right of course
there are periods of conflicts we have
crusades we have colonialism we have uh
other unpleasant experiences with the
western civilization but that's not
that's not the only experience we've had
we've had many positive interactions
many positive contributions made towards
the western civilization so we have to
be clear on these things inshaallah
insha allah i want to give the brothers
a chance to jump in here because i've
been kind of stealing the uh
the seat this whole time
bro i've just been listening man there's
a lot to unpack and a lot to learn
mashallah
yeah
yeah jessica's here for all the
information i have a question though
for someone who gets overwhelmed very
easily what would you
advise them
to like start like where would you
advise them to get started with learning
the history
okay i i always advise youngsters to
start with reading one particular book
and it is titled
um
the lost islamic history okay the lost
islamic history by feras al-khatib it is
an excellent introduction to the muslim
civilization okay any beginner who has
no knowledge of
how the muslim civilization began
and what it became
you must read this book inshaallah
titled
the lost islamic history
okay
reclaiming islamic civilization from the
past something like that and it is an
absolutely amazing book
it is a good introduction it is not
detailed
uh beware
of the fact that it is not detailed it
is a simple introduction to the muslim
civilization for advanced studies you
will have to read advanced books and
what i'm looking for is to inspire
muslim youngsters out there who are
listening to this program to go out and
get degrees
get
masters and phds in history
of your civilization and pick a
particular topic let's say okay a
specific topic and start studying it and
master it okay you won't become a master
of all the history of islam that's not
that's not very possible
with one lifetime
but you can
potentially choose one topic and become
a specialist in that and then you can
always represent that particular
topic when there is a history
when there's a discussion on history
like let's say you can you can study the
history of the ottoman empire and even
within the ottoman empire you can study
the history of solemn
you know
suleiman the magnificent one of the
sultans or you can study the history of
let's say sultan muhammad
okay or you can study the cultural or
or maybe one of the literary aspects of
what the ottomans
left behind okay then you can look at
india you can look at al-andalus spain
you can look at baghdad you can look at
abbasid baghdad for example you can look
at a yubit
egypt or a yubit syria okay you can talk
about crusades muslim experience in the
crusades you can and the list goes on
and on and on and there is so much to
study there is so much to know that it's
unbelievable and how we have been
negligent is also fascinating it's
unbelievable nowadays when you speak to
muslim families and muslim youngsters
you ask them a question what would you
like to become or what will you study at
uni they will say i will study accounts
i will study medicine i will study law i
will study business and all of these
subjects if you ask them why do you want
to study this they will say because i
want to have a career i want to make
money so the primary purpose
now
of education is to make money
which is which is not
which is not right this is not the right
way of looking at education one of the
benefits can be money one of the
benefits can be a career one of the
benefits of your education can be uh you
know a good financial prospect but the
primary purpose of education is to
enlighten you to make you a better
person
to make you
uh a better citizen of the world to make
you a thinker to make you
uh someone who proposes solutions who
give solutions rather than contributing
to problems so
we have lost unfortunately we have lost
the purpose of education so speaking to
muslims in particular and the rest of
humanity in general
okay we need we need diversity in
education we need more muslims in
particular getting involved in
humanities and history specifically
history so that we can actually do all
of this so start with that book
inshallah you will get a very good
introduction
from the lost islamic history again by
feras
it's a very good introduction to muslim
history and then once you have finished
that book
there are so many different topics you
can pick on or pick from
throughout the muslim history
it's dynamic our history is great it's
magnificent
it is so magnificent i mean i i simply
don't have words to explain how how
magnificent and how inspirational muslim
history is
putting aside all the unfortunate events
and occurrences there is a lot of
positive contribution muslims have made
to human history that needs to be
appreciated and understood
so this being said what would your
golden i guess topic of specialty be
i i'm fascinated by a number of topics
looking at my background i
i'm
heavily involved in
interfaith dialogues and debates with
christians mostly and then also
sometimes the jewish scholars so i study
early christian history for that reason
for that purpose i study the history of
christian scriptures for example and
that really fascinates me and it helps
me in my debates and dialogues and
discussions it's good to be informed uh
on the theology and history of your
counterparts for for you to have a
healthy
informed academic discussion so i really
like that history also
uh one of my one of my favorite topics
throughout the muslim history is
basically early islamic expansion
okay how did the sahaba
carve out
such a huge empire within the the first
three generations of islam
and amazingly the prophet of islam
praised these three generations the
prophet says
the best of people are from my
generation and then those
uh that come after and then those that
come after so three generations the
prophet spoke about and these were the
three generations that took land from
land between china and spain okay
within within within a hundred years
allah made a prophecy in the quran allah
sends down a prophecy in the quran in
chapter
24 of the quran verse 55
okay
states
it is the promise of allah to those who
believe among you and do righteous deeds
that allah will grant you succession in
the land so this was a prophecy made by
allah in the quran when the muslims were
cornered from all sides muslims were
facing
existential threats muslims were
militarily cornered they were very weak
and allah reveals this verse to
empower them that don't worry
not only that you will overcome all of
these challenges
you are facing today you will also
take the land
you will overpower the land physically
temporally not spiritually speaking
physically you will take the land
and then the prophet of islam prophet
muhammad also in many reports he
prophesized that muslims my followers
will defeat not only the arabs
they will defeat the persians and the
romans
okay so those who were listening to the
prophet at the time they were thinking
hold on a second
are we are we hearing this right
are we hearing this right is this what
the prophet is saying sallallahu that we
will defeat the arabs
and not only that we will defeat the
persians and the romans okay this was
incredible to use polite terms right
this was absolutely i mean this was
crazy this was mad for some people to
hear this but they believed it because
they knew the prophet sallallahu islam
is a true prophet of allah he's a true
prophet of allah and he cannot possibly
lie and you know when the prophet said
this one of the places he said this was
the battle of ditch
when muslims were surrounded by a
coalition of armies from all sides and
muslims were digging a ditch for their
strong for their for their for the
defense
for defending the city of madina and the
prophet
he while digging the ditch with them and
breaking a rock for them
right
three sparks emerged and the prophet
salallahu at each spark when the spark
emerged the prophet said allahu akbar
they were shocked and the rock was
shattered of course the prophet saw said
the first spark signifies
a victory over the arabs
the second spark signifies a victory
over the persians and the third
a victory over the romans
and what's happening they are digging a
ditch to protect themselves
from the arabs and they don't even know
if they're going they're going to
survive but allah's messenger is telling
them this and what happens
the prophet salallahu
in the year 11
hijri
corresponding to 632
ce
632 ce
and in the year 92 hijri
the year 92 exactly 81 years later
corresponding to the year 711 ce
muslim generals
were in china
in india and in spain
okay
so qut baby muslim was in china
on the borders of china
and muhammad bin qasim
was in current pakistan the province of
sindh
okay
and parikh bin zayad was in al-andalus
in spain
this was the largest
this was the largest stretch of land
ever ruled by one group of people
okay to date to date this was the
largest stretch of land
ever
conquered or ruled by one group of
people
historically speaking with this
speed
greater than what alexander the great
had done
muslims took more land than alexander
the great took from macedonia to india
okay so this was
a prophecy fulfilled word by word
in fact
there is another prophecy
um
in sahil bukhari there's a report
adi bin hatim one of the companions of
the prophet was walking around with him
and the prophet told him
that you know if you live long enough
adi you will see three things three
things happen
one of them is that a woman on her own
she will travel from here which is
northern iraq
she will come
on a beast she will make tawaf around
the kaaba and she will go unmolested
and there will be so much security
in the muslim domain that even a lady on
her own would be able to travel
you know and she won't be harmed in any
way
then
the second thing adi will be that there
will be so much wealth
uh in the coming times you will see that
there will be so much wealth in your
hands that you i mean
people won't be claiming charity from
you
every
muslim will be so rich
and the third prophecy is that you will
open the treasures of kisrah kisrah
so adi was shocked when he heard this
naturally adi said ya rasulullah are you
talking about
kisrah the son of hormuz
are you talking about the persian
emperor in case there is some other
kisrah you're talking about so the
prophet said no i am talking about
kesara the son of hormuz that is the
kisrah you will open his treasure in
other words you will conquer his lands
and you will occupy his treasure and
this is exactly what occurred soon after
in the time of ahmad khattab why am i
telling you all this
i'm telling you all this too and for you
to understand that muslim history is
very dynamic
and muslims carved this empire within no
time within 50 within 70 to 80 years
muslims had taken all this land the
question is what happened afterwards
what happened afterwards and this is
what i discuss in my book you know
islam's war and terror it's a working
title by the way
it is not an established title the book
is still being worked on i'm still
working on
uh i'm very slow unfortunately i'm very
busy in other things so it's taking me a
while to come out with the second
edition the first edition was just a
very quick draft i put out for public to
take information from and i i will be
working on the second edition inshallah
so that it's more detailed and it makes
more sense insha'allah inshallah
so forgive me for my ignorance but i'm
under the impression that your son musa
adnan he's also studying history right
correct yes so there's there's two ways
to look at it usually when this when
this happens usually the sun follows in
the footsteps of the father from his own
accord or the the father had a big role
and influenced the play so which one was
it for your relationship with your son
okay uh in my son's case it was purely
his choice he studied uh he knew i'm a
i'm a i'm i'm a student of history and
he has seen my library
he knows my passion for historical
objects so he knew all that from since
childhood but when he grew up he read
a couple of books on history and he
realized this is what he wants to do he
wants to
he wants to study history so he took
history
on his own accord right but then with my
daughters for example one of my
daughters is studying psychology even
though i advised her to study history
she said i want to study psychology i
said by all means please do so i didn't
force her to study history because she
liked psychology more she went into
psychology my uh
the other daughter she is doing english
she's doing a degree in english in the
english language so i didn't force my
kids to study
the history
i i wanted them to choose
something within humanities i mean i
preferred humanities because every
single muslim parent you look at i mean
predominantly speaking yeah they want
their kids to study something like a
career
oriented
kind of field like where you make money
like medicine law
business accountancy even if they don't
like it and it shouldn't be like that
our kids have to love what they study
they have to choose it for themselves
and that's when they will excel that's
when they will excel that that's when
they will become masters of these fields
instead of being forced by
a particular mindset into studying a
particular subject which they don't like
you know
yeah
yeah
that's uh it's very unfortunate that a
lot of a lot of parents because
i i find it to be the case that a lot of
parents
it doesn't just happen when it comes to
university because that's when you
really try and like specialize you major
in something it happens from the get-go
where the islamic knowledge is really
minimal or even islamic history and
or
i would say any field that uh is super
important in in regards to it not being
super you know or orientalist kind of
lifestyle is is disregarded even from a
young age so it's not just something
that happens at university it's all
throughout life and we go throughout our
entire lives and i'm talking about
myself here you know i went through my
throughout my entire life not knowing
um all of these really astonishing
things so with that being said you you
mentioned and obviously you wrote about
as well muslim and islamic contributions
uh to the world into the west uh more
specifically you know in the case we've
been talking about recently so what
would you say are some of the other like
i would say highlights of islamic
contributions or things that people have
misconceptions about or don't know about
and would most likely be surprised to
hear
people don't have any conceptions
unfortunately you know you can only have
misconceptions when there is something
to conceive okay
there are no conceptions unfortunately
in in most cases people haven't studied
uh the history of islam so all they know
is unfortunately very negative
the newspapers have done a brilliant job
in tarnishing islam and the muslim
civilization and muslims in general
right
for the last 20 years muslims have been
on the receiving end
of
uh an islamophobic onslaught or
xenophobia
or even racism
in certain places in the western world
and this is happening because we are
actually not
you know we're not we're not very active
in doing dawah we're not teaching people
about our civilization we don't show
them the living
side of our civilization so for that
reason we really need to start talking
about how islam
has contributed so much to the western
civilization
it's not that we want uh a trophy we
want medals or we want uh let's say um
you know the western civilization to pay
us back in some sense no
it's to acknowledge it's to get them get
our western counterparts or people
living in the west get them to
acknowledge that islam far from being an
enemy
to the western civilization
is a friendly force it is a positive
force it has always
our scholars our kings our
dynasties have always tried their best
in most cases to contribute positively
right when there was a conflict it was
either imposed on muslims
or
it was caused by some kind of
misunderstanding
right like for example look at crusades
crusades went on for nearly
200 years
for nearly 200 years i mean if we were
to look at
crusades classically speaking crusades
went on from uh 1099
to 1291
okay
1099 ce when the crusaders turned up
at the at the gates of jerusalem and
they massacred the entire population and
then they ruled for 90 years almost 90
years until sultan salahuddin ubi took
back the land of palestine
from the crusaders and then uh crusaders
remained in the holy land for another
hundred years until the mameluk's
sultan beibers
had
taken the lost the last stronghold of
the crusaders in uh the land of
palestine okay so for 200 years
a conflict was imposed upon muslims that
they didn't want to take part in muslim
muslims didn't want any part of the
crusades they didn't want to fight
these western adventurers who had come
from france germany and britain right
this war was imposed on muslims likewise
colonialism
okay what happened during the the the
colonial period throughout the muslim
lands those wars those conflicts were
actually imposed on the muslims by
european colonial enterprises
other than that if you look at muslim
history with the west it has been very
positive muslim works
were
being studied in places like britain
france
and i'm talking about 800 years ago i'm
talking about
when
uh europe was in
the dark ages okay when they said the
dark ages although a lot of historians
now contend that term altogether okay
but there was a period of decline
civilizational decline in europe
okay after the fall of the roman empire
in the west uh your europe went into a
sharp decline okay uh
literacy rates declined
okay um people's uh uh you know expert
life expect life expectancy declined
there were many conflicts there were
many disturbed disturbances that's why
that period is called the dark age okay
for nearly 500 years from the year 500
to 10
1000 okay from the year 500 to 1000
in this period however there was
something very special going on in
western europe and that was in
allendalus spain
for some reason western historians when
they talk about the history of europe
they don't even consider those 700 years
700 years of the muslim contribution in
spain they're treated separately they're
treated as alien history they don't
treat it as the history of europe
strictly speaking okay so if you will
read a book on history of spain
okay
there will be a small chapter on the
muslim period
okay and the rest of it we'll be talking
about
uh catholic kings
from castile from aragon
and from other spanish uh principalities
okay likewise
there's hardly anything on the muslim
uh contribution when it talks about uh
you know when western historians write
to this day
when
western historians write histories of
science
they
either write very briefly on the muslim
contribution or they ignore it
completely
okay this is a big problem
and a lot happened in those seven
centuries in spain muslims ruled spain
or parts of spain for almost
700 years from 7-eleven to 1492.
this is the chronology 711 to 1492
muslims ruled
parts of spain and for 300 years
most of spain for 300 years most of
spain during the umayyad period this was
a period of the golden age
many scholarly works were produced in
the arabic language in cordoba in the
city of cordoba and toledo and seville
and valencia and later on in granada
right a lot of these works were
transferred to european lands
such as france and britain in particular
where these works were translated into
latin
from
arabic and then these latin translations
made from the arabic works
caused a revolution an educational
revolution in europe
which later on basically
uh uh you know accumulated
okay or or maybe resulted in what
uh was known as the european renaissance
which started in the 15th century 1400s
a lot of the european renaissance
in some areas came from
the muslim contribution there is a book
i strongly recommend by a man called
george saliba
yod siliba has written a book titled
the islamic origins of the european
renaissance or the arabic origins of the
european renaissance a very important
book that discusses the muslim and the
arab contribution to the science of
astronomy by the way not many people
know that the university of oxford
was started
uh
the basis or on the bay on on on
it was built upon
muslim manuscripts or arabic manuscripts
that were that were brought from the
muslim world
okay
uh the first science
taught at the university of oxford was
the science of astronomy and
books mostly came from
spain al-andalus
okay
then even philosophy that was taught in
the western world
came through
the arabs
who was a very famous scholar from spain
also known as evie ross
in europe
okay his commentaries on aristotle were
studied in europe by scholars like
thomas aquinas
okay major european philosophers during
the middle ages were studying muslim
works from spain from sicily by the way
muslims ruled sicily for nearly 200
years as well just over 200 years the
island of sicily in italy
now today we know sicily for what
brothers help me out what do we know
sicily for today
i'm not talking about olives and
and and pizza
what what are the sicilians known for in
the u.s let's say
i genuinely have no idea
okay have you heard of sicilian mafias
i was about to say that i was about to
see the mafia okay have you have you
seen have you have you watched this
movie uh the
godfather three series right it it it's
the movie is about sicilian map so what
is sicily sicily known for today italian
mafia sicilian mafias right right but
muslims ruled sicily for over 200 years
and some of the major muslim scholars
are born in sicily
some of their works are studied to this
day al-idrisi
was a famous cartographer cartographers
were basically people who made maps who
were geographers they studied geography
and based upon the study of geography
they made maps one of the most famous
medieval maps of the world is made by
al-adrisi aledrisi was later on active
even in the normal norman court when
normans had taken sicily from the
muslims so muslims ruled sicily for
nearly 200 years and many works produced
in sicily in the arabic language ended
up
in europe through latin translations
spain
produced some of the best scholars in
human history okay those 700 years gave
some of the best poets scholars
scientists for that matter
you know surgical instruments were
invented in spain
and these surgical instruments were used
for
nearly 1 000 years as late as the 19th
century the surgical instruments of abu
kashima
that were invented in spain was used
up to the 19th century as late as the
19th century and only in the 20th
century these instruments were basically
updated new instruments were invented
because of course
we moved on quite a lot with science for
example
other scholars who were born in spain
ibn hasam a great theologian right he
was also
born in spain
one of the best jewish scholars
one of the best jewish scholars
in jewish history was born in spain in
cordoba his name was musabin maymoon
also known as maimonides maimonides
who is known as the second moses in
jewish history one of the greatest
rabbis who ever lived in jewish history
was born in muslim spain in cordoba
later on it took refuge with
uh
the ayubids in egypt because he was
persecuted by
a new
power that arose in spain called the
al-muhads
were a bit extreme and they started to
persecute some minorities and for that
reason some of the jewish families took
refuge in other muslim lands like egypt
right so this history between the west
and the muslim world or the muslim
civilization is very very dynamic it's
absolutely fascinating and one book in
particular
i would strongly recommend
on this topic is hidden debt to
uh islamic civilization
i repeat
the hidden debt to
islamic civilization by s.e al-jazaeri
by s.e al-jazaeri this is a very
powerful encyclopedia of information it
is not necessarily written for academic
fraternity but it is
good for information if you want
information factual information on
muslim contribution to the western
civilization in particular
and muslim civilization in general it is
an excellent piece of work
information packed it is an encyclopedia
of fascinating facts on the muslim
civilization okay and there are other
books i can recommend but i think this
this would be a good start in sha allah
it's
insha
it's it's it's really
well that's so motivating and so
inspiring hearing about you know islamic
history and even when i told just a
little bit um to my little siblings i
saw this look on their face this this
joy and this excitement that subhanallah
a lot of people think history is boring
honestly a lot of people think history
is boring but
honestly i don't know anything much of
it to be honest but it's very very
exciting just sitting here and listening
uh subhan allah
what what i told you today is not even
tip of the iceberg it's not even
scratching the surface as i say you know
once you get deeper
and study muslim sicily muslim spain the
ottomans the moguls in india the ayubids
in egypt
and
let's say you know other dynasties of
islam
the daily sultanate in india okay how
muslims protected india from destruction
during the mongol invasions for 100
years muslim sultans stood like an iron
wall in the way of the mongols
and india
india was protected india was saved from
mongols right because mongols devastated
every single land they went to right and
muslim sultans they gave their lives
their property the children to protect
india to defend india okay i was talking
earlier about this
so the history of islam from india to
spain
from china to spain is is absolutely
fascinating mind blowing you know muslim
art on monuments muslim monuments around
the world if you look at them for
example you will see that some of the
most beautiful
monuments
built in human history were built by
muslims al-hamra palace is an example
it is an epitome of
artistic beauty right you look at
alhambra palace you see geometric uh
patterns on the walls you see the
calligraphy you see the designs you know
when the catholic monarchs defeated the
muslims in 1492 when granada fell to
ferdinand and isabella
they were they they wanted to destroy
the muslim legacy in spain completely
and they burnt one million books
one million books were burnt
in 1492 by these catholic monarchs when
they took the city of granada or the
state of granada for uh from muslims
and when they actually saw alhambra
palace
built by the nazareth
rulers of
uh
granada
they simply could not destroy it they
said this is far too beautiful for us to
destroy
and it stands as
a reminder
for the world
as to how advanced muslims had become in
the imagination
in the artistic beauty and the
expression of love
uh through this art it's absolutely
amazing you know and of course there are
other examples in
in
ottoman lands where ottomans ruled the
mughals left behind monuments like the
taj mahal
and the red fort and all the other
mughal monuments that can be found in
india and pakistan the bacha mosque in
lahore built by the mughal emperor
aurangzeb
all of these things the problem is
uh that our youngsters are not aware of
these things they haven't actually seen
these things to appreciate them they are
more interested in just justin bieber
and
and so-called football stars and music
artists and movie stars and they're
playing games computer games day and
night all day
and i'm looking at my son you know who's
looking at me right now
i'm speaking directly at him you know
they spend all this this precious time
playing computer computer grade games so
my my advice to you muslim youngsters is
at least 10 minutes a day
learn something new about the muslim
civilization go on youtube and type
muslim civilization and you will be
blown away by the documentaries and by
some of the facts insha'allah we just
have to reach out inshaallah
insha allah brothers i i hope i'm not
boring you guys because i think i'm i'm
continuously speaking and you guys
i don't know i don't know i don't know
if you if you if you are actually you
know
i mean i'm sure you're appreciating the
information but when it when when it's
too much when it's too much it's
difficult to take all of it in no we're
we're intrigued the the thing is usually
like
the amount of understanding and new
things that we learn it's not really as
high as it today so we're we're more
listening than than speaking today
that's probably right all right i
understand i understand but you know i
mean you guys are from canada or from
the us me and the romney are from canada
and on the states
okay well even looking at
north america the history of islam is so
fascinating
from the very beginning of north america
muslims are there right did you know
that there were moriscos
that
who traveled with the early spanish
immigrants or settlers who went to
north america and central america
spanish
adventurers and settlers who followed
christopher columbus
and settled in the americas they took a
group
uh called mariscos with them
okay moriscos were converted muslims who
were forced for the who were forcefully
converted to catholic catholicism after
the christians took the land of spain
there was a lot of persecution and
mariscos were there in in america they
they
they had settlements they had colonies
so muslims were there from the very
start on top of that a lot of the slaves
that were taken from africa from west
africa
okay for almost 400 years
okay
of course slavery started in 1450s
what we call atlantic slave trade
atlantic slave trade basically when
european powers picked up slaves from
africa and they took them across
the ocean
across the atlantic ocean to the
americas this was called the atlantic
slave trade okay it lasted for nearly
400 years the peak of it
took
millions of people
from west african countries
to america
and almost 30 to 40 percent of them were
muslims
okay i will repeat
from
you know uh from from the 16th century
to the 19th century
millions of slaves who were taken from
africa
to the americas 30 to 40 percent of them
were muslims some of them scholars some
of them scholars of islam one of them is
a very famous
man called
job ben solomon
job been solomon in arabic his name was
ayub bin salaiman okay
and if you
google him you will see his image with
the turban
with the copy of the quran in his neck
his story is absolutely fascinating mind
blowing okay
and there is a book i strongly recommend
on this topic alone a fascinating
episode of american history with islam
okay
the book is titled the servants of allah
it is titled the servants of allah it
has been authored by sylvian
e dioff
okay sylvian
e d off and get the late latest edition
not the first edition because it has
been added to and it is a fascinating
account of muslim slaves who were taken
across the atlantic from africa to the
americas and how they survived with the
islam how they were hiding in woods and
praying the salah how they were
repeating
the quran or how they were actually
trying to keep the quran by by
doing maraja how they were actually
writing manuscripts in america when they
were slaves
in places like pennsylvania maryland and
the american south predominantly right
and
there was another very famous muslim
slave his name was omar bin saeed
umar bin saeed also uh was a very famous
figure you need to google him and see
you will see him he was
he was born in west africa in the 18th
century and he died in the 1860s in
in
in the american south and you see some
of his photographs black and white
photographs omar bin saeed so this is
also another side of the muslim history
which is often not uh appreciated and
known to many people you think there is
yeah i was gonna say we had uh we had a
couple of scholars that they told us
that and they were african-american uh
brothers or african canadians and they
used to say that you know our people
used to be muslim and i was like what do
you mean and they were like you know a
couple generations back we were muslim
exactly we were talking about then they
lost islam after coming here they were
given white names and then generations
after they found islam subhanallah
absolutely absolutely and and the reason
why so many afro-american brothers are
coming to islam
is because it's part of the dna it's
already there in the psyche somewhere
one of the ancestors who was enslaved he
probably prayed to god that oh allah
make my progeny muslim okay i cannot
keep up with my islam because they were
lashed they were brutalized they were
branded they they were worked to death
and at times in circumstances like this
if they if they tried to pray they were
tortured and they were brutalized there
were many many difficulties they faced
and
within a generation islam was lost
unfortunately
they couldn't keep up with the islam
because of the circumstances but those
who could
they did their best in keeping up with
islam and when you read the book uh
servants of allah by silvian idiot
it will blow your minds away it will
make you cry at times seriously when you
look at the struggles of those muslims
in america at that time and what muslims
are going through today is is is
comparatively is is this there's nothing
in comparison to what the muslims had
been through previously you know from
different parts of the world
yeah
you know as soon as you mention that the
first thing that came to my mind is like
we're dealing with like nothing's found
allah yeah we have it so easy and people
like there is the world it feels like
people are are you know starting to
forego their deen and they're not even
facing any kind of real adversity or
struggles upon allah but um that brother
you mentioned ayub suleiman i remember
seeing the video there was a video post
on instagram about him i believe their
video was titled um
the uh the fortunate slave or something
like that yes that's right there's a
book
the fortunate slave yes there's a book
on him
wow
yeah published by oxford university
press the fortunate slave he was
fortunate because he was able to free
himself he was a scholar
uh he
is basically he was he was discovered by
some scholars in britain
the law the story is very long because
he wrote a letter in arabic to his
father to pay ransom for him so that he
can be freed and the letter somehow
ended up in london some people in london
they read the letter in the arabic
language and they asked who wrote this
they said a slave wrote this and they
said this is not a slave
the one who wrote this letter is not a
slave he's a scholar and we want him we
want him to be in london so they paid
for his freedom
his american master freed him he ended
up in london for three years nearly
three years he stayed in london he met
the royalty he was a celebrity in london
he was even painted by
an accomplished artist and the painting
you see online is that painting
he has a copy of the quran in his neck
hanging and he's wearing his west
african turban you know very islamic in
his attire and he wrote two qurans from
memory
he wrote two copies of the quran from
memory while he was in london okay so
fascinating and this happened in 1730s
1730s almost 300 years ago and he
returned home
to current day senegal and he found his
wife
had married someone else because she got
a fatwa he went missing for years of
course so she had no idea usually when
people went missing that time they knew
they're not coming back so
she she had gone for god of fatwa and
she got married to someone else and his
father was killed in a conflict with
another tribe and he found his world
turned upside down when he got back to
africa fascinating story of ayub bin
salehman yeah
wow subhanallah yeah honestly after this
inshallah i'm going to do a lot more
research on that because
that like five-minute summaries is
motivating in and of itself and i
remember this feeling when i first like
just watched that short clip talking
about it of just inspiration allah but
uh although this has been amazing
hopefully inshallah we can do it again
because there is just honestly not
enough time in the world very
unfortunate but my last question for you
adam rasheed is you said you collect
historical you know artifacts that's one
of your passions right
what is your most cherished cherished
historical artifact that you own
ah a good question a very good question
i will try to show you an image of it
online so that you can see it
this is one of my most cherished
uh
items
for
obvious reasons when you will see it you
will see what i mean by that okay uh
let me quickly
share an image of it with you so that
you can see what i'm talking about
uh this is one of the earliest muslim
dinars
in history
okay
when i say muslim dinar i mean one of
the earliest muslim
coins in history can you see it
it's very clear right yeah yeah
masha'allah so how old is that
this
was minted in 78 hijri
wow okay
this is basically the second dinar in
the series the first dinar ever minted
by muslims
when i say dinar a properly islamic
dinar with all
islamic
information on it
previously they were minting imitations
muslims are minting imitations
for pragmatic reasons they didn't change
the the
the currency but
in the year 77 hijri
abdul malik bin marwan and umayyad calif
he minted the first properly islamic
currency
and this is the second
item in the series
because it's from the second year the
first year was 77
and by the way that year if you buy that
particular dinar it is worth minimum 200
000 dollars u.s dollars
[Music]
so the only affordable the only
affordable dinar in the series is the
next one which is 78 hijri okay this one
so if you read it i will read it for you
you can see bismillah there
you can see bismillah
and then move move the other way and
anti-clockwise
okay it translates in the name of allah
this dinar was struck in the year 78
and it was most
it was most probably it was uh it was
struck in damascus in damascus and in
the middle there in the middle you see
you have allahu akat
allahu say
this is
uh
the reverse of the dinar if you want to
see the obverse
then i will show you the obverse very
quickly as well
where another verse of the quran or
verse taken for taken from the quran is
put down and you can see that as well
insha allah
this is for all
my young muslim brothers and sisters who
may be watching this podcast okay this
is the other side
okay in the middle it says
okay then when you read anti-clockwise
from here where my finger is sorry where
my finger is there it says muhammad
rasool allah
so
this is
you can say the first islamic dinar in
the history of islam and it is very
close to my heart is one of my most
precious
possessions you can say okay uh because
of its historical significance i cannot
afford uh
the one from the year 77 so the only
affordable one was 78
so i recently i recently acquired it
alhamdulillah and this is muslim
heritage you know and even behind this
coin there's a lot of history and
there's a lot of history why did abdul
malik bin marwan
even come up with the idea
because previously what happened was he
was using uh the byzantine the roman
uh solidy
uh the roman currency in gold was called
solidus right he was using those
for
trading for taxation for all all the all
the necessities
and then he was advised that we must
have our own currency
our own gold minted with islamic
formulas rather than using byzantine
currency with crosses with the with the
with the image of the king and all that
so malik bin marwan was the man who
minted these coins
i'm really excited that that you showed
us this and i'm even more excited to
have you back in sha allah inshaallah is
there anything that you would like to
ask us or anything that you would like
to tell us before we wrap this up in sha
allah thank you so much for having me
i'm really grateful and this is my
second podcast for the day i had i had
another one with the south african uh tv
station earlier so it's my pleasure to
always talk to my young brothers and
sisters out there to to to appreciate
our history more to study it more to
take more interest become coin
collectors i mean i encourage you to
become coin collectors collect coins on
the muslim civilization okay
and it's very easy to do that go on ebay
and you will find a lot of things you
can start collecting it will really
start the process of your interest in
muslim history inshallah and then read
books on the history of islam pick up an
easy book to read start with the basic
book and then make your way up slowly
and then you will start to see
the giants we
we stand stand on we are standing on the
shoulders of giants as they say you know
so we are literally standing on the
shoulders of giants
and
you just have to find out thank you so
much for having me really appreciate it
yeah this honestly has been a pleasure
and honor and hopefully insha'allah we
can do it again very very soon in
charlotte my pleasure
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that's crazy because
y'all know how like impactful it was
yeah isn't it if you're watching this it
was so it was such a strong dream
that i woke up
and then i was talking to my dad and i
was crying
because how strong the dream was how
impactful the dream was
and then i ended up driving to uh the
mosque it was like 5 40 something
to do fajr at the mosque and i was
crying the entire way to the mosque
and subhanallah i think it's crazy
um
[Music]
[Music]
hmm